Приїхав  у Вінницю вчитися на юриста, потім в Київ вчитися на юриста,
Потім в Київ на Майдані тогрувать пивом,
Потім став дизайнером, потім, корочє, плюнув, поїхав сюда
Дивишся: така красота.
Всьо, буду вже тут
Сюди йди, коняка
Тяжко нести, жалко
померти
прррть
прррп... Стій
Погнали
Тут якби більше дикого, знаєш, такого
Ви б в жизні у нас борть не побачили
Тут ти приходиш - борть
Блін, прикольно
ліс, ти понімаєш, поля тако, знаєш, місцями
Можна ходити, з лісу не виходячи сутками,
Всьо
Тут посіяв квіточки
І не хочу я нічого більше
Ну оце я кошу, шоб тут такого, як там не було,
Шоб було красіво
От коняка для того й є, так  би я фіг би косив
а так вона заставляє це робить
Чорнобиль бахнув - багато втекло, багато приїхало ліквідаторів
Тобто тут тоже  мішка населення
Чорнобиль це ж
Він як Ейфелева башня,
Він як піраміди, як Статуя Свободи, - його весь світ знає. Це такий об'єкт,
кругом якого треба шось робить. Сам Чорнобиль, Прип'ять -
це фігня буде. Саме цікаве - це шо робить природа без людей,
які експеременти
Це об'єкт, який живе. Всі плачуть за тою цьою, шо ловить, - вишка,
"Дуга-2". По суті, і без "Дуги-2" зона лишиться
там треба робить якісь діскавері тури з цими джипами, знаєш,
Як з цим фестивалем. Ми його за місяць
зляпали!
В Україні таких лугів майже немає, з озерами,
заливні, всі десь пріватізіровані
І тут так круто: просто гуляєш, ходиш, відпочиваєш
Тут якби людей, які підключалися, взалі не ожидав
більшість не ходила
Конфлікт із мєсними. У нас, корочє, 50 на 50.
Половина за реформи, а половина - "не мішай, там у нас рай"
з пенсіями усе, корочє, схвачено
Вони пострадавші, чорнобильці
Не держи п'ять коров, а держи п'ять туристів
кожен день. Це вигідніше буде
А кожному не має сенсу говорить.
Знаєш, це буде поверхневе
Сємєчкі поїли і пішли додому. Краще одному чи двом об'яснить
Класно, а вони друге зроблять
Я хтів ліру, а грошей не було. Склепав
Її зразу купили. Думаю, ніфіга собі, ще зроблю. Ще купили.
Я ще зроблю. І так до сих пір. Але вона
надоїла мені вже.  Но я би грав би, но не робив би їх.
А мусиш, приходиш, бо гроші треба
Її зробити навчити когось
За тиждень можна
Це заготовка на ліру, так
Ше не ліра. Ну, корба кована. Знаєш, така
Кантрі стайл такий
Це взагалі білоруській діаспорі
да, в нас і в них лірники побутували
Де кінчається ліра, кінчається Європа
Дальше - як відрізало. Ніколи не було
ні згадок, нічого. Цих не було нігде аналогів
Якшо там струнні, щипкові, смичкові, - це  були по всьому світу
там і в Африці, і в Азії, то ліра була
винятково тільки в Європі
То кобза стара. Но вона тоже, бачиш,  з чого попало
зроблена. Якшо подивишся тут
з серцевини дерева - це неправильно.
Це одна з перших моїх робіт.
♪
Вже відвик, навіть, як на ній грати забув.
Спробую з банкою.
♪
У травні ми плануємо зробити музей-експозицію, тимчасову.
Тут можна щось побудувати, типу Сталкер кафе,
немає місця, де можна було б нормально похавать.
Також можна хостел зробити, страйкбол, сплави по річках.
Плавали б до Дніпра,
туристам цікаво.
Це девайс, щоби плавать.
Цей човен буде широкий,
тут ще борта можна нашити.
Тут, бач, заготовки, крюки такі — це боті називаються. Шпангоути по-научному.
- Якщо правильно зроблений човен і оброблений...
- На все життя хватає людині.
Тут зараз більше ніхто не робить їх.
Взагалі мало хто займається цією справою.
Я, принаймні, не чув, щоб хтось робив.
У всьому є нюанси.
Перед тим, як почати довбати човен
потрібно його розмітити, щоб він не перевертався.
Був стійкий.
Борті, човни, довбанки — це традиційне Полісся.
- Тато подивись!
-Дивись не впадь, подивись.
Щоб ще в воду бовкнувся.
- Я на таком вєліку вже навчився!
- То все, купляємо тобі такий вєлік?
- Да!
- Главне "да" сказать!
Добре, колись...
Треба попробувать, чи ти на Настіному поїдеш.
- Шапку поправ!
- Може він завеликий, а цей замаленький...
- Да?
♪
Ми організовуємо фестиваль і намагаємося зробити скансен.
Скансен - це музей архітектури.
Це ми робим для замовника, невдовзі мають приїхати екологи.
Все чим я займаюся - це все мені цікаво, це все моє хоббі.
Тобто я не збираюся цим займатися, я хотів би, щоб хтось це зробив.
Спочатку я був "місцевий": мав худобу, ходив крити дахи.
Потім награвся і зрозумів, що так все життя мине.
- Бачиш - місце для вогнища, пеньочки...
Я музикою не займався вже вісім років.
Раніше щось грав, виступали на фестивалях.
Щоб взятися серйозно за якийсь проект, то такого не було.
Зараз вже пів-року, як повернувся до цього.
Планую гастролі в США і інші країни.
Знімаю кліпи.
Тепер я зрозумів, що повернувся до того, ким я хотів бути.
Музикантом.
♪